look at his reaction there that is oh
he's gone to have a little lay down
after that so uh oh dear look at that
he's sitting in the corner like a
naughty child yeah so he now relies
realize Queen takes
Magnus can't believe it
I don't think we've ever seen a reaction
like that we've nearly never seen a
missed opportunity like that from the
world's best player and who's gonna
recover Magnus looks nice straw he's had
enough now
and uh the thing is you can't even move
the King after that check as well I mean
it was force check mate I mean there was
no way to avoid it because the Knight
would have come in at the same time and
uh I've never seen that before you know
missing a mating free from the well-jack